so um hi and welcome everyone i'm tim
morton i'm founder and cto at akunu
i
will tell you a little bit about the
um the background of a kunu so we um
so we started out building a storage
engine in fact a storage system for
virtual
machine environments so looking at block
storage and this was sort of 2009 2010
and we recognized that sort of pretty
soon after that we've got some great
technology it sort of it all worked
quite nicely but we recognized that
there wasn't really a market for the
sort of uh ability to to
to manage
large volumes of structured data in the
context of a block environment you know
at one end you have sort of ebs and at
the other hand you had emc and there
wasn't really a middle there so we
thought hey what should we do with this
cool technology we've built like every
startup does and we
plugged it in to
the set of sort of distributed databases
that were coming onto the market at the
time and
one of them that we really like the look
of and
uh
that seemed to work pretty well
especially compared to the other ones at
the time was cassandra so
we sort of offered cassandra with the
storage engine for a little while and
that was all going well but we sort of
really observed that one of the
challenges that people had around
uh using cassandra was uh was how do you
how do you build analytical applications
on top of it so you know cassandra a lot
of the use cases that we were seeing
were people trying to get back i guess
sort of rich query semantics and
framework that people
were familiar with and coming from a
relational a relational background
so
that's i guess the genesis of acuno
analytics so i'll tell you a little bit
about that and then go on and maybe
maybe show it to you if uh
if the wind is coming from the right
direction and and so on
so i guess the first thing is
like analytics on nosql does it even
make sense why
would you not just use hadoop and i
guess the the sort of answer to that is
that um well you should use hadoop you
should use hadoop for the sort of
analytics where you don't really have a
good idea about the question you're
trying to address in advance and where
you're trying to tackle
data sets with a large amount of variety
and not very much structure and that is
really a perfect fit for for the world
of hadoop and
indeed hadoop has really taken over from
or supplemented the traditional world of
data warehousing because
it um allows you to deal better with
data sets which are which are
unstructured so if you're trying to find
the unknown unknowns or you know the
sort of so-called needles in a haystack
to help you inform some business process
six months down the line you know you're
really interested in how meteorological
data is going to affect your widget
sales and you need to tell your sales
force to do something subtly different
and send a memo out at the end of the
week then hadoop is a great fit for
being able to tackle those sorts of
problems and i sort of call that
discovery analytics you know it's data
mining uh doing a bit of complex um
machine learning and you know
generally generally trying to
do arbitrary computation on very large
unstructured data sets
um on the other side of the spectrum and
this is i think where nosql and
general and i think cassandra in
particular are a much better fit and
where there are many more sort of uh use
cases and case studies of people doing
this sort of thing uh is is around what
i would describe as operational
intelligence so here you're not trying
to find the needle in a haystack you
probably already know what the metrics
are that matter to you in advance so
you
are perhaps you're monitoring a whole
huge cluster of servers and it doesn't
take a hadoop cluster to tell you that
um looking at your 95th percentile
latency of api calls or looking at load
averages is a metric that should matter
to you if you're in advertising looking
at click-through rates it's clearly a
metric that matters to you you know that
from your own domain knowledge right and
so operational intelligence i guess is
about being able to build dashboards and
build
systems which react to
changes or potential problems in those
metrics rather than sort of discovering
new metrics in their entirety so
um and in particular often that
contains a sort of real-time element so
uh
in particular particularly you're
looking at sort of use cases where five
minutes matters you know if there's a
business decision you could make better
on the back of fresh data or if there is
um i guess you know something you can do
to sort of raise the alert raise the
alarm and go fix something uh because
you've spotted that's broken or because
something's gone wonky or even better do
it predictively before something that
goes out of out of uh out of band or out
of out of bounds then
that's that's great uh cassandra is a
great platform for doing that sort of
analytics on
and here you're really dealing much more
with velocity rather than variety volume
just sort of these days tends to feature
all over the place
so
you know we've been contributing to
cassandra for a long time and we've been
using it and like it's great to see uh
to see you know it's continued adoption
uh it is
has it has some great properties so in
particular it's it's it's highly
scalable you can just add machines and
increase capacity increase performance
and
the multi-master architecture that
cassandra has means that
it doesn't create you operational
headaches as you grow it
it's very very fast in particular it's
very fast for writes and that's really
useful when you're doing operational
analytics because what you tend to do
there is you're collecting this big
stream of data or perhaps you're
collecting or trying to record
information perhaps you're counting
stuff about this big stream of data and
you're potentially reading it back uh
showing on dashboard or or raising
alerts much less frequently so your
write rate to read ratio is is often
like a hundred or a thousand to one
that's typical for the sort of customers
that we work with so the fact that
cassandra is very very good
at writing fast is
is is
important it's also
highly available i think it's one of the
only stores
out there where within sort of 10
minutes you can set up a cluster and
tell it to spam three data centers and
it'll just do it in a sensible way and
that's a that's a really
really really useful uh useful thing if
what you're looking to do is make sure
the system is always on to be able to
collect data or always on to be able to
serve those results
so it is dependable it's not always been
dependable since uh you know back in the
days of 0.5 and 0.6 but um
you know what's
what's really um what's really pleasing
to me is that there are many uh what i
would class as sort of
risk-averse organizations who are
beginning to
deploy cassandra in mission critical
settings and it has really it has really
hit the mainstream in that sense
um and it also has atomic counters which
are the building block of analytics
being able to
basically throw plus ones at the store
allows you to
build graphs and quantitative analytic
applications on top of cassandra
so all of that's great right so the the
that
there's always still a challenge though
because no sequel giveth and no sequel
taketh away so this cartoon was not
about cassandra obviously um cassandra
doesn't really need you to write
distributed mapreduce functions in
erlang but the point still stands right
um not wanting to put too much fun at
our friends over in the react world
actually
it is still pretty hard to query
cassandra so
you know you put your data in and
then you have to pull it out roughly in
the same way that you put it in and the
sort of whole process of denormalizing
your data which cassandra encourages
means that you need to think in advance
about how you want to read data out of
cassandra and that's fine
unless you get into the situation as uh
as as bob and his mate do here
is mate at britishism i think it might
be uh
anyway bobbins may have got into the
situation where um
you know
bob wants to query the database himself
right um you know in fact there's a
middle step right which is that you
build this great application and then
the requirements change and you then
have to query in some other way and you
have to change your cassandra data model
to adapt to that and that's a real pain
and in particular if you then need to
roll that back over historical data
that's really hard as well because you
have to probably write scripts or you
have to munch it in some way
and then the step beyond that is when
bob wants to be able to ask queries
himself and has to become an expert in
cassandra data modeling which is getting
considerably easier with the advent and
improvements in cql3 but it
you know it still ain't at the position
and i don't think it ever has really
intended to be where you can just give
it to a business user and let them let
them loose on it
so
we wanted to to change some of that and
working through working with a number of
customers are saying earlier
who were just starting out with
cassandra data modeling and particularly
data modeling for analytical
applications was certainly the hardest
problem that uh that they were
encountering so we built this thing
called a kunu and i'll dive into a bit
of technical detail about it in a sec
but basically
you take events so we have a http api
where you can just throw a json at it
with flume integration kafka integration
and and a range of other things now
and basically it just sort of does your
data modeling for you you
describe tables
and sort of dimensions like the the
sort of fields that correspond to the
keys in your in your in adjacent objects
say and say this is a time or this is a
this is a path like a sort of
hierarchical structure or it's a number
and we basically turn
those uh tables and sort of the
templates of the queries that you want
to ask on them into
into operations on cassandra so an event
turns into rights on cassandra and we
use cassandra to store both the raw
events and these intermediate and these
intermediate results as well
and the reason we do that is because we
then allow you to ask queries of it in a
rich sequel like language and we
decompose those queries into uh reads on
the sort of data model and this
materialized view we've built so you can
think of this as basically like
olap on top of nosql so we let you build
olap cubes and update them in a
continuous fashion and rather than
you coming back to your data warehouse
the next morning and getting the results
from yesterday
and getting a sort of cubing environment
set up from yesterday where you can sort
of slice and dice your data actually
that just happens continuously and we
can do that because of the great
features that cassandra has
and on top of that we also built a bunch
of dashboards so like a browser-based
set of dashboards i'll show you uh to
sort of help you visualize all this
stuff in real time
so
how does this work so the first step is
that you define aggregate cubes this is
sort of logical progression right so you
define you say you know we keep the
spirit of denormalization that cassandra
has and we um
we basically ask you to say tell us how
you're going to be querying your data
but in a sort of much more sort of
templatized sense so
a cube consists of an aggregate function
something you want to do with the data
and a set of dimensions that you might
want in a where or a group by clause so
here we're going to build a cube which
takes the approx
the prox top five or ten or whatever
keywords um
and we are gonna want to be able to
specify and filter by browser and by
time and then we wanna be able to group
by time buckets that are sort of
granularity there so
what happens is we
as we collect these events we
do the work to update all of the
potential places in the materialized
view that you
that that event features so
for example if you're counting by day or
counter by hour of day or counting
uniques by hash tag or something like
that
and the event
features in a range of different places
in these cubes we will convert that
single event into multiple rights which
is
fine because cassandra has great ride
performance
we also stored the raw events as well
i'll come back to why in a sec but when
you ask a query in the uh the kunu query
language which looks as you can see
cunningly like sql you basically
what we're doing there is just
decomposing that into
reads basically get slices in cassandra
on these on on these cubes
and
the
i guess the benefit of doing that the
key observation here is that we're never
having to touch that original data if
you're going to ask a query so if you go
to hive and you do select count from
your whole data set that's going to take
a while because it's going to go over
every record and it's going to have to
pull all of that back so
the whole purpose here is that by you
guys specifying what you the sort of
shape of queries that you want to build
in advance we can do the work as events
come in so that you can get instant
answers
that's the basic idea
but we do maintain mappings to the raw
events as well so if you spot a
particular outlier in your latency
distribution and you want to drill into
that and find out particularly why uh
why that's occurred you can still see
the raw events through that
and of course then when your boss comes
and changes their mind about the
requirements and says it would be great
if we could have this different cube or
if we could group by this other
dimension or could you show me this
other dashboard um we allow you to oh
and by the way i want results for
yesterday as well because i want to
compare them we allow you to take the
raw events we diff the schemas work out
the underlying data that we need to um
we need to change in order to be able to
get that historical data and backfill we
basically backfill by pumping that those
raw events into the new cubes
does that make sense
cool
so okay let's do a concrete example so
um
basically imagine you've got some data
like this so we break uh every cube
is represented in cassandra by um
not every cube
i guess a table will be broken down into
a set of column families in cassandra so
under the hood we are maintaining a set
of materialized views so each cube is
basically a materialized view and the
basic way of thinking about it is a
where in your cube is a projection onto
a particular row
and a group by roughly is a set of a set
of columns within that row
and for each sort of set of hierarchical
aggregates say you want to be able to
count by hour and you also want to be
able to count by minute
each of those represents a sort of
a step of
a group in your columns and a set of
rows as well so here for example just to
sort of understand that right what you
want to be doing is when i say
uh something like
uh select count where time is is within
an hour and group by minute i want to be
able to do as little work in cassandra's
possible to pull those that data out so
the way we organize that is to to have
the hour
as
the row
the row key there and to be able to have
the
minute as
column key
so
a single get slice operation in pre-cql3
terms allows you to
allows you to get that answer and of
course the original event
has to update a whole bunch of different
counters so just talking about cancer
for now
and and likewise if i want to do
something like where geography equals us
group by user uh
the user features in the group by
in the column key and the uh
the row keys us and of course you can
see that you end can end up if you've
got multiple columns
sorry multiple dimensions
in your where clause you can end up with
sort of compounded uh row keys
so that's the
sort of very basic a basic example so
there's a number of other things that
you can do with this so
we support hierarchical aggregation as
well so you can break
urls or paths of something like data
center rack
machine down we support arithmetic
expressions limits
you can do filtering and query time we
deal with time zones so if you are
inserting events with a whole range of
different time zones and then you want
to come back and query 10 o'clock
pacific through to 1157
utc we'll piece together the buckets
that are available
with with a minimal amount of effort and
just return you the overall results and
then you can do inner and outer joins
that
warning that happens at query time
it's designed as a convenience thing for
you to do on sort of low cardinality
dimensions is not designed to replace
sort of massive into machine joins in a
data warehousing context so
and then you can do sort of sql sub
query type things but i personally can't
get my head around sql sub queries so i
think a pipe uh for syntax is much
easier to think about where you can take
the result of one query on a cube and
then ungroup or regroup or summarize by
by something else so in that example
doing some of a particular value some
and counting
from v group by category and then
basically taking the sum of s and sum of
c as the actual average of those
those separate aggregates
so
so so far like i guess what we've been
talking about is really uh making ingest
simply giving you a http json based api
uh making uh queries richer making the
process of denormalization a bit less
painful but still giving you some of the
benefits of it and giving you some
visualizations
if you see what you have here it's
basically still a tool for developers so
if you look at this sort of workflow of
install create tables define cubes like
plug in your data feed and then build
widgets well only the
only the widget building bit is really
doable by bob
right everything else bob is sort of
still has to go and pester
this other guy for
so one things we wanted to do is change
that a little bit so we released
analytics v5 last week and one of the
things we so bob still has to that the
other guy has to still install it one of
the things we did there was really try
and improve the workflow for business
users so try and give you the equivalent
of one of the rich bi tools that you've
had for years in sql
in
the world of nosql in particular and
only on cassandra so we
now allow business people as i'll sort
of demonstrate to um basically create
create schemas by having the equivalent
of sort of an autumn automatic import
wizard that looks uh very similar to the
one that you'll find in excel
we allow
business guys to build widgets by adding
a sort of drag and drop ui which sort of
does an ad hoc query and then works out
what cubes you need to fulfill that
creates those cubes backfills them and
then
updates for real-time
data of course as it comes in
you still need to get this other guy
back involved when you turn on the data
feed but that's getting a bit easier
we've built a set of ingestors and and
other sort of add-ons so that you can
just from the command line plug in
different data sets and and that's
definitely getting easier and then you
can re you know that your developer then
can get out of the picture and get on
with more useful stuff and you can leave
bob to go and iterate on the analytics
and dashboards that he's been building
so
um okay you guys will see that
so i'm going to start with a fresh
analytics instance
here
um
and
what i'm going to do is just
upload a file that
we prepared earlier of slightly munged
tweets
so i'll show you i'll show you what they
look like um so they're basically just
json events right so they're json
objects with like keys and values inside
them in fact the keywords here have been
split out so maybe we're cheating a
little bit but um we you basically just
give it a set of events and
we will then
look at those events and work out what
the structure of them is so we sort of
correctly uh infer the time stamp as a
time we uh completely incorrectly a
further keywords as a path
so
we also support this type bag which is a
bit like a set of tags so if you send an
event with a sort of an array of uh
strings in it we'll sort of process
those and pull them out for as a bag
um
if we go over here use a country string
um great
that's good
tweets path here that's wrong should be
a string
so
i don't really need to know very much
about cubes or or analytics to be sort
of doing this um the sort of target
audience is somebody who can use a pivot
table in excel
so
i've just
created my enormous big data set of 40
tweets from my file and uh now i want to
do some big data analytics on all 40 of
those tweets
i think they're a fortune there anyway
so i can drag count
up here yeah 40. and i could this is
just doing an ad hoc query from the raw
events at the moment there's no cubes no
cubes here at all
and
um
so
let's group my country shall we so
i group my country i
get a picture which breaks that count
down by my country
um
i could turn it into a map
if i can find the map
there we go
and at this point maybe i'm happy with
it
so you can see underneath by the way
that there's a
there's a query that's going on here so
we do an event store query we pipe it
through and we sort of do a fake cube
query and by the way for every query in
here you just have to say all the ui is
doing is just using our http api which
is available to your applications and
we'll just give you jason back yes okay
so you load a flat file right yeah if
you are if you actually want to have
cubes
do they need to be pre-created in this
files or
somehow i couldn't figure it out later
you just load flat files and create
later
yeah so that's what's happening here so
i've just uploaded a file and there's no
cubes in here yet
so this is just a so
if you watch when i click add to
dashboard here
basically this is the cube i need right
i need to count from tweets group by
country but i'm missing
i'm missing that cube so when i
so new cubes will be created to support
instant updates as widget so when i
click add widget
um that cube will be created and with
that tick box field it will populate it
with
my vast amount of historic data
so if i refresh that
yeah there we go so now it's on a
dashboard
um and i can drop down to
uh pull in some twitter dates some
twitter data we
we put together this twitter ingester uh
which
i
will uh attempts to start
let me just grab the
so
we have this plug-in framework now for
ingestors where you can basically
write your own or download off github
different types of ways of getting data
into a cuny so you have this notion of
an ingester and then a flow so flow
basically takes data of a particular
sort and pipes it through to a table in
in analytics so
the table that got created i'll just go
and show you that the table that got
created was
basically have these fields that we
created and it's now got one cube
in it
so when i go through and
create that flow
fingers crossed
it'll
go to twitter and pull us in some events
although it did try and rate limit my
api key earlier so there's no guarantee
that that's going to happen
oh there we go we've got some okay so if
we go back to the dashboard we just made
um
you know what let's so i can
change the visualizations on it later as
well so change your pie chart if i make
that live let's see what happens
all right so we're getting some twitter
data about countries
and then
talking about drilling down to raw
events if i can click canada here you
can see the tweets that were coming in
from
from canada
yeah country canada
that's basically it and i didn't really
need to understand anything about a cube
before uh creating those visualizations
which makes things an awful lot simpler
and all of this is powered by cassandra
and we are doing this in across a range
of verticals from like web and visitor
analytics through to financial uh market
data analytics investment banks and uh
internet of things and
um
it's just trying to make rich queries on
cassandra a sort of a step easier
okay thank you
any questions
how do we why is it how do we license it
so um so analytics itself is closed
source everything we do at the cassandra
layer we push back into the community
but analytics itself is closed source
it's a sort of annual subscription
basis
i can chat to you more about details
sorry
how do we do it
so
so so by taking the definitions of the
cubes that you set up we work out what
we're going to need to insert in rows
and what we're going to need some
certain columns and build a data model
that maps
maps that so under the hood we're
creating we have create a key space used
by default called analytics and then we
create column families within that which
match
the
cubes that you set up
and then we have to do
because cassandra's got some limitations
on your ability to change the schema
after the fact
we sort of have to do a bit of funky
serialization of our own to to to sort
of make that work so say you want to
change a field which you first declare
as a number into a string and then you
want to create a different cube on it so
we at that point we end up having to do
a bunch of uh our own serialization but
more or less all we're doing is um
mapping sort of higher level constructs
about like i want to cr i want to query
this data uh with this in the where
clause and this and the group by clause
onto a set of data models uh
basically a set of constructs in
cassandra for you
what happened
so what happens if your event
definitions change well you can go and
change these things if you if you like
so
for example i can
add a field so i can go and change that
uh and i can add a new field uh if i've
already been collecting events with that
field that's absolutely fine we'll have
been storing those events and then you
can come and backfill them and pick up
that data from those events you've
already collected so
yeah you can change the structure as you
go either by adding new fields dropping
fields um dropping cubes or changing
cubes
so it's just
to try and make the whole
you know changing of requirements
process a bit a bit simpler
does it create another cube or does it
reprocess
so when you change the schema so in
terms of adding a new cube
yes
right so yeah so i add a new say i want
to do something like i want to do a prox
count distinct of
keywords and i want to be able to
group that by
country
when i click add cube i'll create a cube
and that will build a set of new
potentially a new column family but
certainly a new way of storing data
within potentially existing column
families in cassandra and it won't touch
any of the raw events unless you click
this button here which says backfill
so at that point we will then take a
slice of data
from the past and basically do this
distributed process where we
roll over the raw events and pull them
back into this new cube so you can get
historical context but if you don't care
about history on this new cube you don't
have to do that obviously that's a bit
like a map produced it takes a while
so if i have an operational dashboard
and it has
i don't know seven graphs
do i have seven potentially up to seven
different cubes
uh yeah
yeah
if if
the if the graphs are showing different
things so you might have graphs which
are showing you know
uh clicks from
people in
california clicks from people in oregon
and maybe they're the same cube but just
with different parameters filled in so
cube
a cube represents like a sort of
unparameterized
shape of
query storage over here if i have a
right so
you're right so there is definitely a
space blow up by um
maintaining materialized views so i mean
the question
just for the recording the question was
what's the space blow up if you've got a
terabyte of data um
however cassandra has built-in
compression which is actually really
really good and also all we're doing is
just for most of these things is
counting so
numbers don't really take up a lot of
space it's actually the keys that are
the
the large the large element um
so we do have some data structures which
aren't counts like so we support a prox
count distinct for example which uses
a sort of probabilistic sketch algorithm
to
give you
a better performance on count distinct
which is quite hard to do and there the
sort of space is sort of customizable
you can choose how how
how big they are in fact there you go
there's the size field just there
but the um
uh
the short answer is there is a blow up
of course it depends on how many
analytics how many sort of cubes you set
up but it's not as big as you might
think
okay cool i want to stop there and hand
over to nicola who's gonna
tell you about virtual nose thanks
okay welcome to this talk on virtual
nodes
uh the
feature that we call the operational
aspirin for focus on
i'd like to start with a one minute
recap on how sonic distributes data in a
cluster so
cassandra is a distributed database it
tries to spread your data set across
multiple nodes and the way that it does
this is using a technique called
consistent hashing
nodes are clustered in in a structure
that we call the ring so this is a
picture that i will reuse
in this stock in this case we have four
nodes
each one having a quarter of the data
set
so think of it as
like a clock face in which you have uh
between zero and three o'clock all the
data goes to the yellow node et cetera
so the way you configure this in
cassandra at least before virtual nodes
is by giving a token to each node so in
this case
the blue node has token 0
the yellow node has token
max token divided by 4
max token divided by by two three
quarters etcetera so if you have ten
nodes you would take this maximum token
uh divide it by ten and then give zero
times this to the first node one times
this to the second node etc
this is something you have to do by hand
when you set up your cluster
uh the way that exoner used to do it is
using md5 uh reduced to 127 bits instead
of 128
uh now uses murmur 3 which is 160 bits i
think
but
it doesn't really matter which hash
function it uses the point is that this
will distribute data all across the
cluster
evenly
as long as your partitions obviously are
are set up properly if you set up
one partition which is just between zero
and one o'clock
your your one note out of four will only
receive
uh
one key out of twelve only
okay
so this has some limitations and in
particular the main problem is the
operational complexity of the system
um there are some problems in uh setting
this up it's quite error-prone uh we
frequently see people getting this wrong
and ending up with
unbalanced clusters which can cause
problems
it's also
a liability when you try to
rebuild the cluster
in a way that we'll see in a little bit
but the main point is that when you try
to add a node or remove a node you will
not involve your whole class type only a
local fraction of it
which is not exactly what you would want
from a peer-to-peer master less
decentralized distributed system
in terms of maintenance as well
there are some some processes that you
need to run in cassandra in particular
something called repair
in which
the nodes will synchronize themselves
in a distributed fashion and this
involves
without virtual nodes only
in the same way a small fraction of the
cluster
when you add or remove nodes when any
sort of topology changes changes happen
when you add the data center
this is a manual process it's quite
tedious
and right this is now a modern way of
distributing data
so let's take the example of of adding a
node to an existing cluster we have this
cluster of four nodes uh it's balanced
right we have 25 percent of the data on
each node
and we want to add the fifth one to
accommodate for uh for growth for uh
more throughput etc
so the way we we would add it in the
first place is to insert the new node in
the cluster this new node would come up
at around five o'clock let's say this
would this is a random uh random pick
but if it comes at five o'clock it only
has a twelve
of of the whole ring which is not what
we want we want
all these notes to have
something like well to have 20 of of of
the ring
so there is a manual process in which we
need to move each note from the original
token let's say zero 25 percent fifty
seventy five percent to zero uh uh
twenty percent and uh 2040 et cetera
this process is manual this is something
you need to do per node and as you can
see uh the data that was originally at
let's say at at six o'clock i was on the
green node and now it's been transferred
to the uh the new node right
so this involves data transfer in your
cluster
if you do it node by node you can see
that it only involves the immediate
neighbors
of of the new node in the ring
this is time consuming it's resource
intensive as well
and it is generally a pain
to do at least in small clusters so what
people tend to do is
uh at least for small clusters is to
double the number of nodes you can see
here that
from four we move to eight
which means that we only inserted
a new node let's say at
12.5 percent which transferred some data
from the yellow node to the orange node
but didn't need to do anything else
really
this doesn't really scale when you're
growing for for um
from more than eight notes right you
can't really uh justify spending uh
double the money every single time
usually what people do above eight or
ten nodes is to uh start a new data
center so they push this problem a
little bit further in time but uh is
still in general an operational pain
so the way to add or remove nodes is to
uh insert this this new node with a new
token and rebalance those ranges
so
ranges are these these partitions these
uh
slices of the the whole data set that
belong to a node or another
in general this is something that people
do wrong
either they make mistakes in the
calculation of of the new tokens or they
will move more data than is optimal
right if you add a new node
from uh
from four to five maybe you'll leave the
one that's at zero and you'll move the
one that's at 25 to 20 percent so you're
moving five percent of your data to the
new node to to another one but in
general uh you will not go through the
most optimal process so some there are
some
commercial tools that will give you a
rebalance option i will try to calculate
the minimum amount of work
for for rebalancing but if you do it by
hand you'll probably do it wrong at
least a little bit
as i said it only impacts the
immediate neighbors of a node so it only
impacts
replication factor nodes that are around
the one that you're currently moving
if you have a hundred nodes all for some
of our customers two thousand nodes
uh moving
a few out of several thousands is is not
really the uh the most efficient way of
of balancing uh of spreading the work
among those nodes
it's all right it's manual tedious air
prone painful and in general it's now a
thing of the past
removing the node is is
a pain in the same way and it is pretty
much the same operation in reverse
in a way that people will
for small clusters uh divide the number
of nodes by two and removing one node
will involve the same process except in
reverse when you have your five notes
with 20 each if you remove one of them
you will have to rebalance all of uh the
the surviving ones to uh 25
um
right so this is a limitation not just
in terms of operational pain but also in
terms of scale
in a way that if you have
a plan for
the availability of your system and if
you plan for let's say at most a node
being down for
a whole day for 24 hours
then having a limit in
the amount of of data that you can
stream in one day
means that you cannot really put more
than let's say one or two terabytes of
data per node
if you have two terabytes of data per
node rebuilding a whole node replacing
it or removing it or adding it will take
about 24 hours of just streaming data
into the system because only the
immediate neighbors are involved in this
the solution is then
this new feature new
uh called virtual nodes
returns our
new ish in cassandra 1.2 uh
1.2 came came out in december last year
so it's starting to be a an established
feature and i recommend you definitely
use it uh if you're not at the moment
the main point of this is is to have
more than one token
instead of having a single spot on the
ring
for which which defines the range that
you're responsible for which includes
all the data up to that token
you'll have more than one token per node
the way to do it is if you have more
than one token per node if one token was
difficult enough to set up
it will not be a manual process it is in
this case a random process so each node
will assign its own tokens at random
as we'll see this actually leads to
a balanced distribution of data even
though that might seem
counterintuitive
what uh the good features of version is
that they let you grow your cluster one
other time instead of doubling the
number of nodes they remove this
operational pain of having to
recalculate
tokens and having to
manually set up your cluster that way
in the same way removing nodes is
supported
with the same ease
um other good things you're now
streaming
data when moving partitions when adding
or removing nodes you're streaming data
from all nodes instead of just the uh
the local replicas
the main downside
although it's not
that consequential is that only random
partitions are supported now
traditionally cassandra used to have two
ways of distributing data either using a
hash based partitioner called the random
partitioner or now the murmur 3
partitioner using this hash function
that then dispatches data all over the
place or you could have
a manual token assignment
in which you would say all the users
with name from a to f would go to this
node from g to l would go to that node
et cetera
this was quite tedious and and
error-prone as well
that doesn't really work with virtual
nodes and it's not tested with virtual
modes
okay and multi dc multi-date sound
support
just works in the same way now
so virtual nodes means having more than
one token per node there are different
ways uh to do this it means that now
we're splitting the token space the key
space into more than
four
partitions into more than four ranges
for four nodes and there are different
strategies so the one that christian
roman point two uses
uh is to have if you consider n the
number of nodes
and b the size of your data set
the number of partitions here would be
proportional to the number of nodes
typically in cassandra 1.2 and over you
would have 256 partitions 206 ranges per
node
so in our full node cluster that's
ranges that are spread all over the ring
it means that the partition size in this
case uh grows in proportion of data but
also uh
is is lowered by having an increased
number of nodes
uh it's a bit different from
the way that react distributes data
react has virtual nodes as well but you
have a fixed number of virtual nodes
in the whole cluster and this is defined
when you install rare
and mongodb although i'm not
i'm not certainly not an expert on on
but i believe this is how it works
with auto shouting that you have
a certain number of partitions which
depends on the size of the data i think
that's the case also if you use hdfs in
which the partitions are really the hdfs
blocks that are spread across your
cluster
so versions are new in 1.2 and it's
important to talk about them now because
they
are now enabled by default in version
2.0 which came out in in september
the way to do it if you're starting a
cluster today is to set num tokens to
in cassandra.yaml i say that it's not
enabled by defaulting 2.0 this line
exists in a config file it's just
commented out
in customer 1.2
so let's see how it works when you we
start a single node uh it will start
with 256 tokens
well this one has about 10 or so
i said that these tokens are generated
at random so they split the ring into
256 ranges of various sizes as you can
see here some of these ranges are larger
than others
sometimes
a lot larger than others
adding a new node
will
also generate 256 new tokens and spread
those across
the cluster so by injecting its own
tokens into the ring a new node will
steal some data
from the existing nodes in this case
there's only one so the one that joins
will then
start to own the the ranges that are
here represented in green
when we add a third node it will also
inject its own tokens into the ring and
steal a bit a little bit of data from
the green node still a little bit from
the red node etcetera
you can see how adding more nodes to the
cluster will lead to a more balanced
version
a more balanced distribution
in this case
so in practice it is very close
to 1 over n for all your nodes
it's true that it's not exactly that
you it defers often by a few percent but
really is not it's not a big deal in
practice it doesn't really matter at all
an ideal distribution would be that all
the nodes have ranges of equal size
completely
spread across the cluster
actually it looks more like this or you
have ranges that are a lot larger than
others
but the distribution of ranges
is is such that
some nodes will have larger ranges
but
it will balance out in the in the
global picture
adding a new node so that this process
called bootstrap will then uh
assign a host 256 tokens
split ranges from existing nodes
and it means that instead of having data
sent just from the local neighbors you
have
the new node steal data from all the
existing nodes and this will stream data
in from you from your whole cluster it
will involve all your nodes
in bootstrap
right so
what you get from this is right no need
to rebalance you just add one note to uh
grow your cluster and you could uh
remove one node uh one at a time as well
so if we remove the one that has the
blue ranges we end up in the same
situation as as before it will release
some of the nodes that some of the
ranges that it stole from the green node
to the green node
and and same thing for the right node
removing the node is now called node
tool remove node because remove token
doesn't really make sense if you have
more than one token per node
so nodes have now a host id which is
just a randomly generated unique
identifier
the tokens are all removed from the ring
and the data is released uh not just to
the immediate neighbors but to all the
other nodes in the ring
so no tool ring which is the the first
command you you run in your cluster
becomes quite useless if you have a
thousand ranges
to display this is not something that
will really be meaningful
in your in your environment
it becomes replaced by noodle status
in which you can see this host id and
you can see the uh the columns called
owns which is the
the the sum of um
all the sizes of the ranges that this
node
is is responsible for over the size of
the whole ring so in this case i just
started five nodes
at random
uh i didn't change anything in the
configuration just made sure that the
virtual nodes were
set up properly and you can see that
i've got pretty much an even
distribution i have one node as 20. 21.3
percent of the data but
that doesn't really matter this at this
stage
it also means that
having heterogeneous hardware
is now possible if you have
one node with 156 tokens and one with
128 tokens the one with 128 will
seal ranges that are
still fewer ranges so it will only have
half the data as
as the other one
this was quite difficult to do
with
with cassandra 1 1 and before
because you had to have an unbalanced
ring on purpose you had to skew your
token so that i know you would have 12
instead of 25
but well it looked wrong on the on the
whole picture
okay some math
um you run some some simulation on uh
what it means to have uh
uh random ranges so
this is just running uh
simulated token assignment uh if you
pick let's say 10 nodes and you give
them a thousand tokens each
you just insert them at random in this
token space and you look at the
distribution of range sizes and you can
see that
well there are some ranges that are much
larger than others and some ranges are
much smaller than others but this is a
distribution that applies not on the
whole it plays on the whole cluster but
all the nodes have the same distribution
of some large ranges and some small
ranges
this is what uh this is where this
distribution this even distribution
comes from not that
there is a skew in the distribution of
range sizes themselves but that all
nodes have the same distribution
so we
run the test in simulating
data insert into this cluster and this
is roughly what we got
you can see that
on the x-axis you have uh the virtual
node location that's really the the
token itself between zero and
one billion let's say in this
if if that was your token space
and in on the y-axis you have
the amount of data stored per node and
as you can see some of them are much
much larger than others in practice this
is something you would see
if you were to represent all the all the
tokens
in a ring fashion you would see that
some of them are really close to each
other and some of them are quite far
apart
when you put this together
in
in the whole cluster you end up with
distribution which is very much centered
which is very much a normal distribution
centered on
the expected amount of data that you
would have for
n ranges in that space so you have an
nth is centered on one end
and being the total number of virtual
nodes a total number of tokens
in in the ring
so in this balanced cluster cluster
we now have
keys that are
randomly distributed evenly distributed
in the cluster by the random partitioner
and in practice it does tend to
balance itself out so i run the test
just before before the stock started two
nodes they started with 48 and 51
percent
three nodes
almost a third four nodes
almost exactly 25
uh in practice if you have 60 nodes they
will be completely equal
we also did some performance testing to
validate these claims of faster
bootstrap and decommission
we started the 17 node cluster on ec2
instead inserted almost half a billion
keys into that
and i timed how long it took to remove a
node or to add a new one now sorry to
remove a node and then to add it back
removing a node took about a third of
the time
well it's not exactly 17 times faster
but you can see that it's it's a massive
improvement and bootstrapping
was quite a lot faster as well
it didn't sound that impressive now keep
in mind that this was about a year ago
there's been there have been quite a lot
of improvements
in the streaming protocol of cassandra
i would expect this to be much better
now
ah
so versions are great how do you use
them if you have an existing cluster
this is kind of the pinpoint of virtual
nodes there are different ways that you
can migrate an existing cluster
to virtual nodes
the simplest way is just to start a new
cluster inject your data into it and
then destroy your old cluster if you're
running in a virtualized in a cloud
environment that's something that's easy
to do but you'll have some some downtime
because you're effectively restoring
from from backup
if you want to do it without downtime
you can
create a new data center
uh so that would be twice the hardware
and i start to replicate the data into
the new data center
and when this is done i destroy the old
dcm
you need then in this case twice the
hardware that might be possible
depending on your on your case
there is an official way of of migrating
to a v-not cluster which is called
shuffle
shuffle is a utility which is bundled
with cassandra
the way it works is
it will you would stop one node at a
time and then start it again with
virtual nodes enabled so if you think of
your four nodes in this
equally divided quadrant
uh of 25 each if you stop one node then
enable virtual nodes there and then
started it again what sonic will do is
identify that there was
a running cassandra cluster cassandra
node there with 25 of the data it will
take this range and split it into 26
tokens
these will be consecutive and divide
this quarter of the ring into
partitions of various sizes
you you do this for uh
one at a time for all your nodes and you
end up with a cluster with virtual nodes
in which
you you're not really distributing all
this data you still have uh the point
about virtual is that you're supposed to
have all this mix of of partitions
together so the way that shuffle works
is that it will take two partitions and
then swap them
say okay now you're responsible for this
and you give me the other partition and
it will do this uh quite a few times
until
the data is sufficiently shuffled
together and you have effectively a mix
of
of virtual nodes everywhere
um
i don't think i've ever seen anyone use
shuffle
successfully have you yes
well you're the one
so
eric who used to work at okuno and who
wrote shuffle i said that it worked on
his laptop
that was the the only guarantee we had
so far so okay i'm glad to hear that
someone managed but
uh it is quite broken i would say so
the recommended ways would be uh
well to
provision more hardware and add notes
like this
so you should really be using versions
by now uh if you haven't then this
there is a
migration path migration path
uh it is worth it uh because
managing tokens and uh shuffling data
together moving data together
by hand is is really a pain
um
and this will let you grow your cluster
and and uh
in a much easier way
right thank you